ZDF heute live einen schönen guten Abend
ja gut eine Woche nach der
Bundestagswahl ist nun die erste Runde
der Sondierungsgespräche abgeschlossen
alle in Betracht kommenden möglichen
Regierungsparteien haben jeweils
bilateral miteinander gesprochen und da
ist es für uns an der Zeit mal eine
erste Zwischenbilanz zu ziehen also
welche Regierungskoalition könnte da
womöglich am Ende bei rauskommen welche
passt am besten zueinander wo gibt es
die größten Gräben wie könnten
Kompromisse aussehen und ihr könnt und
sollte wie immer gerne Fragen dazu
stellen und auch mit diskutieren
zunächst aber sprechen wir mit zwei
jungen frisch gewählten
Bundestagsabgeordneten nämlich mit zum
einen Zoe Meier Bündnis 90 die Grünen
sie ist 26 Jahre alt hat ein Master in
Wirtschaftsingenieurwesen und holte ihr
Direktmandat für den Bundestag in
Karlsruhe herzlich willkommen und wir
sprechen mit Maximilian Mordhorst von
der FDP 25 Jahre alt Jura Student holte
seinen Mandat über die Landesliste in
Schleswig-Holstein wo er auch
Landesvorsitzender der Jungen Liberalen
ist erstmal einen schönen guten Abend
ihnen beiden und herzlichen Glückwunsch
noch mal zum Bundestagsmandat
vielen Dank
ja ist er noch nicht so lange her
vielleicht mal vorweg einen guten
abendliche Frage genau danke eine
persönliche Frage sind sie beide zum
ersten Mal also in den Bundestag gewählt
worden wie fühlen sich jetzt die ersten
Tage für sie beide an das ist ja schon
was besonderes jetzt mittendrin in
diesem koalitionspoker zu sein
vielleicht Frau Meier machen Sie den
Anfang
ja ich finde tatsächlich diese aktuellen
sitzungszeiten hier sind so ein bisschen
wie die erste Woche im Studium also so
ich sehe ich das zumindest man bekommt
gerade unglaublich viele Informationen
man lernt unglaublich viele Menschen
kennen und muss natürlich auch erstmal
verstehen wie dieses ganze System
Bundestag dann auch in der Praxis
funktioniert aber alles sehr sehr
spannend natürlich
also dieser Vergleich mit der ersten
Woche gefällt mir sehr gut wir haben
tatsächlich eine ganze Menge gesehen und
erlebt ist es ein riesiger Apparat und
wie der funktioniert da muss man noch
eine Menge nachschauen von dem was man
außen vorher schon kannte er ist das nur
ein Teil und deswegen war das wirklich
eine aufregende Woche und das geht auch
weiter so ja es sind insgesamt
aufregende Zeiten auch für uns
Beobachter noch ist vieles im Fluss
viele Fragen natürlich sind noch offen
aber klar dürfte ja sein dass es
erstmals jetzt auf ein Dreier Bündnis
hinauslaufen wird und dass ihre beiden
Parteien jeweils mit dabei sein werden
davon gehen wir mal ganz stark aus
schauen sie seitdem anders auf die
jeweils andere Partei wie ist das zum
Beispiel bei Ihnen Herr mortos haben Sie
jetzt einen anderen Blick auf die Grünen
auf einmal
also das wäre ja komisch wenn sich der
Blick auf die eine andere Partei ändert
ob man vor dem Wahltermin oder dahinter
steht es gibt weiterhin inhaltliche
Differenzen es gibt weiterhin Dinge wo
wir Übereinkommen was mich sehr freut
und das hat man erst nach der Wahl
logischerweise gesehen ist dass wir
beide bei den Erstwählern sehr gut
abgeschnitten haben und ich glaube da
sind auch Gemeinsamkeiten die man bei
dem man untereinander sieht und sie
haben völlig recht jetzt müssen wir
zusammenkommen und dafür ist auch die
richtige Zeit Frau Meier stimmt zu nehme
ich an
klar also natürlich im Gegensatz zum
Wahlkampf da war es ja vor allen Dingen
wichtig auch die Differenzen zwischen
den einzelnen Parteien hervorzuheben zu
sehen okay wo liegen denn die
Unterschiede und jetzt ist der
Rollentausch wir müssen eher gucken wo
finden wir denn irgendwie zusammen und
wie kriegen wir es hin auch eine
Regierung zu bilden die dann vielleicht
auch tragfähig ist für die nächsten vier
Jahre und das ist natürlich noch mal
eine ganz andere Herausforderung ja so
viel seiner vorweg gesagt wir können
hier natürlich keine
Sondierungsgespräche nachstellen oder
simulieren das passiert aus gutem Grund
und ja relativ diskret mehr oder weniger
was man so hört und liest in Berlin aber
wir wollen ja trotzdem mal die
inhaltlichen Positionen ihrer Parteien
anschauen auf die ist ja dann ankommen
wird aber zunächst wollen wir noch mal
kurz reinhören was die Spitzen von
Grünen und auch von CDU heute nach ihren
ersten Gesprächen das war die letzte
zwei runde in Berlin zu sagen hatten
klar ist in gerade
gesellschaftspolitischen Bereichen
stehen unsere Parteien eher weiter
auseinander darüber haben wir auch
gesprochen was es für Differenzen gibt
und in anderen Bereichen gibt es
entsprechend auch gemeinsame Anliegen
wie die Modernisierung unseres Landes in
einem guten Austausch man konnte in
vielem gedanklich noch mal an 2017
anknüpfen wo wir ja schon über viele
Themen auch gemeinsam gesprochen haben
und wir glauben dass ein solches Bündnis
eine breite in der Gesellschaft hat die
es wirklich möglich macht das Land in
den nächsten Jahren zum modernisieren
voranzubringen
ja soweit also die Spitzen der Partei
noch mal der Hinweis an unsere User
gerne Fragen oder Kommentare an uns
schicken auf den bekannten Wegen die
wollen wir gerne mit ins Programm nehmen
Frau Meier wo wir gerade dabei sind wie
finden sie denn eigentlich eine
Zusammenarbeit mit der Union die soll ja
bei den Grünen nicht unumstritten sein
gerade die Grüne Jugend hat sich sogar
explizit für eine Ampel ausgesprochen
und würde Jamaika gar nicht gerne sehen
also sie haben schon ganz richtig gesagt
zu den Sondierungsgesprächen können wir
heute nichts sagen und ich möchte dazu
auch nichts sagen das ist gar nicht
meine Rolle an der Stelle sondern wir
haben da einen sehr tolles
sondierungsteam dass mein absolutes
Vertrauen hat und das auch ja das
Vertrauen der Fraktion hat an der Stelle
und deswegen genau zu allen
Sondierungsgesprächen und Optionen
einfach an der Stelle keine Aussage
wunderbar sie sind zwar erst kurz im
Bundestag aber ich merke schon sie haben
die Mechanismen verstanden kommen wir
auf die inhaltlichen Knackpunkte zu
sprechen wir haben uns drei Themenfelder
mal rausgesucht wo wir mit Ihnen beiden
Trennendes aber auch übereinstimmen das
ausloten wollen und dabei wollen wir sie
jeweils auch konfrontieren mit einer
Experten Einschätzung und zwar mit der
von Professor Stefan kurz vom Kieler
Institut für Weltwirtschaft den wir vor
der Sendung befragt haben unser erstes
Thema Steuerpolitik
Stichwort steuern die FDP lehnt
Steuererhöhungen eine Vermögensteuer und
eine höhere Erbschaftssteuer ab der
Solidaritätszuschlag soll schrittweise
abgeschafft werden die Abgabenquote soll
insgesamt auf unter 40% sinken die
Unternehmensteuern sollen auf 25%
gesenkt werden die Grünen wollen kleine
und mittlere Einkommen entlasten dafür
soll es einen höheren Spitzensteuersatz
eine Vermögensteuer und Steuern für
Umweltbelastung geben lassen sich diese
Gegensätze überbrücken und wenn ja am
besten mit Union oder SPD
hier wäre es am einfachsten wenn man
sich auf ein Jamaika-Bündnis verständigt
denn die Union liegt ja etwa auf der
Mitte zwischen beiden Positionen und
jonat deutlich gemacht sie möchte die
Steuerbelastung erstmal im großen und
ganzen so belassen wie sie ist und das
ist dann so etwas wie der naturgegebene
Kompromiss zwischen Steuerquote erhöhen
und Fehlerquote senken
also Herr Mordhorst die Steuerpolitik
ist natürlich das Steckenpferd der FDP
wir haben den Experten gerade gehört das
wäre leichter die Pläne umzusetzen mit
Jamaika als mit der Ampel ist für die
FDP damit die Sache quasi schon durch
überhaupt nicht es ist völlig bekannt
und das sagen wir auch immer wieder dass
wir mit der Union in der Wirtschafts-
und Finanzpolitik viele Schnittmengen
haben das wurde gerade beschrieben wir
wollen entfesseln wir wollen
Entlastungen ermöglichen gerade in der
Mitte der Gesellschaft und wir glauben
dass auch Klimaschutz das wurde ja auch
gerade bei Steuern angesprochen durch
Innovation am besten funktioniert
natürlich gibt es das Schnittmengen mit
der Union aber alles weitere wird man
jetzt sehen denn es gibt auch mit
anderen parteienschnittmengen Frau Meier
ihre Partei will besser verdienende
stärker besteuern sehen sie da Chancen
auf Kompromisse auch mit den Liberalen
ja für uns Grüne ist natürlich ganz klar
wir wollen eine Finanzpolitik und eine
Steuerpolitik die für die gesamte
gesellschaftlösung anbietet und eben
nicht nur für einen kleinen wohlhabenden
Bereich unserer Gesellschaft
dementsprechend ich sehe da schon die
größten Differenzen auch mit mit den
Verhandlungen die jetzt auch eben mit
der FDP oder in den Sondierungen die da
stattfinden aber ich glaube nicht dass
es unüberwindbare Differenzen sind aber
sicherlich werden das noch mal
spannender und ja nicht ganz einfache
Gespräche
das glaube ich gehen wir mal direkt da
ich noch keine Fragen von unseren
Zuschauern zu diesem Thema jetzt gesehen
habe das werden jetzt meine Fragen an
sie noch mal zum zweiten Thema über das
ist dann im Prinzip direkt die
Klimapolitik da okay ich höre gerade der
Beitrag ist noch nicht da dann bleiben
wir auch gerade bei diesem Thema Steuern
und genau dann noch mal vielleicht die
Frage an den
FDP-Abgeordneten Herr Mordhorst also sie
hatten schon gesagt das wäre leichter
mit der Union was macht sie denn
zuversichtlich dass es da auch mit der
SPD bzw dann eben auch in einem
ampelbündnis verbindendes geben könnte
naja ich habe es ja gerade gesagt also
die größten Schnittmengen in dem Bereich
haben wir mit der Union das ist bekannt
es gibt aber zum Beispiel einen großen
Bedarf und den sehe ich zumindest auch
bei Grünen und SPD in der Mitte und
gerade bei kleinen Einkommen Steuern zu
senken oder zumindest Abgaben zu senken
wir haben ja gerade bei den kleinen
Einkommen die große Belastung bei den
Sozialabgaben ich glaube da ist eine
Bereitschaft vorhanden daran zu gehen
und das wäre ja schon mal ein erster
Schritt insofern ist das nicht von
Anfang an ausgemacht wie gesagt
grundsätzlich mit der Union haben wir da
zumindest bei dem Thema die meisten
Schnittmengen aber gerade bei kleinem
mittleren Einkommen gibt es aus meiner
Sicht auch da Bereiche die man zumindest
gut und konstruktiv diskutiert und Frau
Meier da würde ich gerne auch noch mal
ihre Einschätzung zu hören also sie
hören jetzt auch noch mal hier von ihrem
fdp-kollegen dass die
Jamaika-Koalition da das einfachere
Modell wäre ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass sie da bei der Ampel ja doch eher
sehen würden dass sie ihre Positionen
dadurch bringen
weil die Wahlprogramme anschauen da
haben wir natürlich mit der SPD erstmal
mehr gemeinsam als auch mit der CDU und
geht es ja auch darum eben gerade die
kleinen und mittleren Einkommen zu
entlasten und da sind sicherlich größere
Schnittmengen mit der SPD da
gut dann haben wir dieses Thema im
Prinzip jetzt für unsere User zumindest
so ich das jetzt hier richtig sehe
besprochen ich sehe immer noch keine
Fragen oder Kommentare wenn wir jetzt
noch mal gerade hören wollen in der
Regie ist denn inzwischen auch das Thema
Klimapolitik vorliegend oder müssen wir
uns noch etwas der Steuerpolitik widmen
dauert noch einen Moment gut dann würde
ich vielleicht noch mal über die
einzelnen Steuern mit ihnen sprechen
wollen also es war ja auch von der
höheren Erbschaftssteuer die Sprache die
die FDP natürlich ablehnt auch die
Vermögenssteuer warum eigentlich wenn
ich da noch mal nachhaken darf ist das
für sie ein untaugliches Mittel
es ist ein untaugliches Mittel das ist
genau der richtige Begriff es ist ja
völlig richtig dass man darüber reden
kann dass die Schere zwischen Arm und
Reich eher auseinander geht nicht so
sehr bei den Einkommen aber bei den
vermögen wir haben aber gesehen und das
zeigen auch
bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteile bei den
substanzsteuern also wo man Vermögen
besteuert und das gibt es eben bei
Erbschaftssteuer und Vermögenssteuer
gibt es ein extrem hohen bürokratischen
Aufwand Vermögen ist ja nicht das was
man auf dem Girokonto hat sondern es ist
alles was man im Eigentum hat und das
ist extrem schwer überhaupt
herauszufinden und zu besteuern und dann
ist eben die Frage wie macht man welche
Freibeträge da habe ich leider von
anderen noch keine gute Lösung gehört
und wir sollten gerade daran denken dass
es auch Menschen sind mit viel Vermögen
die dafür sorgen dass es auch
Arbeitsplätze in Zukunft gibt deswegen
ein untaugliches Mittel hat schon in der
Vergangenheit nicht funktioniert lieber
an anderen Stellen ansetzen und wie wäre
das dann zu finanzieren denn dadurch
geht ja auch Geld verloren und
beziehungsweise nimmt man halt eben
nicht ein was dann vielleicht an anderer
Stelle gebraucht würde eingenommen
werden müsste
völlig richtig wir müssen das ganze
finanzieren das kann man einerseits
machen indem man die Stollen erhöht das
ist nicht das was ich für das richtige
Mittel im höchstabgabenland Deutschland
halte also wir haben schon die höchsten
Abgaben der Welt man kann auch mehr
Steuern generieren und das ist vor
Corona 10 Jahre so geschehen indem man
Wirtschaftswachstum hat also mehr
Steuereinnahmen durch eine stärkere
Wirtschaft dadurch höhere Steuerabgaben
und dadurch auch mehr Steuereinnahmen
und das ist das was wir präferieren wir
lassen da haben das auch das
info-institut hat das ausgerechnet bis
2025 pro Jahr 4% Wachstum ist jetzt
nicht wahnsinnig viel wäre es möglich
unser Programm zu finanzieren
wir haben eine Stimme über Youtube einen
Kommentar oder bzw eine Frage an Frau
Meier wuffgang fragt nämlich wo kann man
Steuergelder einsparen aus Sicht der
Grünen bevor man welche erhöht was
würden Sie antworten
ja also das Thema Steuermittel einsparen
da gibt es sicherlich viele
Möglichkeiten wir haben jetzt ja auch in
den letzten vier Jahren gut gesehen wie
es nicht funktioniert beispielsweise das
Thema ja Maut also da wurden ja auch
Verträge schon geschlossen bevor
überhaupt irgendwie auch klar war ob
sowas rechtlich halt bauen möglich ist
also wir haben im großen Maße
Steuerverschwendungen in den letzten
vier Jahren auch gemerkt wie es
funktionieren kann das möchten wir nicht
und gegen so eine Politik stellen wir
uns ganz klar es sind aber auch viele
kleine Sachen das Thema
Entbürokratisierung Digitalisierung
dadurch haben wir natürlich auch ein
enormes Einsparpotenzial in unseren
Verwaltungen und Co das ist jetzt zum
Beispiel auch ein Thema wo wir
vielleicht mit der FDP dann wieder auch
auf einen Nenner kommen weil da stehen
ja unsere beiden Parteien für wir wollen
gerade die ganz starke Digitalisierung
und den Aufbruch in Deutschland
voranbringen
verstanden ich lese gerade noch mal zwei
Kommentare vor über Youtube sie schreibt
Lindner hat eine viel attraktive Rolle
in der Ampel jamaika ist eh nur noch
Verhandlungsmasse und nicht mal die
könnte man in der CDU Laschet dass die
Meinung von Sea auf Youtube Stefanie
Müller wiederum schreibt wenn Jamaika
kommt gehe ich nicht mehr wählen der
Wähler Wille ist dann nicht beachtet das
ist ja in der Tat ein Problem was man
vielleicht hätte in der Kommunikation
von Jamaika ich weiß nicht wie sehen sie
beide das
wir haben ja noch mal auch Erhebungen
gehört auch Ende der Woche nach der Wahl
das in der Bevölkerung Jamaika relativ
unbeliebt sei es gibt ein klares Votum
für Scholz statt für Laschet wie sehen
sie beide das
ja also vielleicht einfach mal da wir
haben ja auch während des Wahlkampfs
fängt an damit wir uns vielleicht genau
da müssen sie uns von Seiten der
Moderation nachhelfen weil ich glaube
wir haben so ein kleine Sendepause von
drei Sekunden also so einen kleinen
Verzug ja genau also vielleicht noch
einmal kurz dann die Frage
genau also wie es aussieht im Bezug auf
die Nachwahlbefragungen und ob denn auch
eine Jamaika-Koalition nicht schwer zu
vermitteln wäre kommunikativ angesichts
des Wahlergebnisses
ja klar also für uns war erstmal die
ganze Zeit im Wahlkampf auch klar und
das haben wir klar kommuniziert wir
möchten am Ende mit allen demokratischen
Parteien reden die für eine
Regierungsbildung auch zur Verfügung
stehen und auch tatsächlich dann zu
Mehrheiten führen würden deswegen ist
jetzt einfach zum aktuellen Zeitpunkt
noch nicht der richtige Zeitpunkt
gegeben um da auch Koalition
auszuschließen sondern das kann sich
erst dann ergeben wenn wirklich auch die
Gespräche gewissenhaft mit allen
Beteiligten geführt wurden weil ich
glaube das stärkt auch unsere Demokratie
am Ende dass wir eben nicht vorher schon
immer sagen ah okay mit denen geht es
aber auf keinen Fall und nur hier haben
wir die stärken sondern dieser ganze
demokratische Prozess lebt einfach auch
davon dass man am Ende die inhaltlichen
Schwerpunkte zusammensetzt und dann auch
inhaltlich sagt wieso es eigentlich
nicht funktioniert gut dann würde ich
dieses Statement jetzt mal wenn ich das
da für sie beide so stehen lassen und
würde dann gerne damit wir zeitlich den
Rahmen nicht völlig sprengen zum
nächsten Thema überleiten das ist
nämlich ja das Thema sozusagen der
Grünen schlechthin es geht um die
Klimapolitik auch hierzu noch mal die
Positionen der Parteien und dann auch
wieder die Umsetzung von Professor kurz
Stichwort Klima die FDP will dass der
co2-emissionshandel auf den gesamten
Verkehrssektor ausgeweitet wird die
EEG-Umlage und die Stromsteuer sollen
wegfallen ein mögliches Verbot von
Verbrennern lehnt die FDP ab wenn es
nach den Grünen geht soll der
Strombedarf bis 2035 vollständig durch
erneuerbare Energien gedeckt sein der
Kohleausstieg soll bis 2030 Erfolgen der
CO2-Preis soll bis 2023 von 25 auf 60
Euro pro Tonne erhöht werden ab 2030
sollen keine neuen verbrennerautos
verkauft werden lassen sich diese
Gegensätze überbrücken und wenn ja am
besten mit Union oder SPD
in der Klimapolitik steht es zwischen
den beiden koalitionsmodellen eher fifty
fifty die Frage ist dann wie sieht es
mit dem begleitenden Maßnahmen aus
insbesondere ist es ja so dass die
Klimapolitik auch Verteilungseffekte hat
und je stärker man dort den Ausgleich
unmittelbar über den Staatshaushalt
sucht würde man natürlich dann eher eine
Koalition mit der SPD suchen allerdings
die SPD hat auch andere
ausgabenträchtige Programmpunkte und
dann wird es irgendwann sehr eng im
Staatshaushalt
ja also offenbar auch ein Thema das
nicht so ganz leicht aufzudröseln ist
aber wir versuchen es mal Frau Meier die
Klimapolitik also ist ja der Markenkern
der Grünen in welcher Konstellation
haben sie da das Gefühl könnten sie ihre
Ziele am besten durchsetzen und warum
ja für uns grün ist natürlich ganz Klar
Klimapolitik steht jetzt auch im Fokus
das steht ganz sicher auch im Fokus für
die Sondierungen und mögliche
Koalitionsgespräche das ist der Anspruch
mit dem wir als Partei jetzt auch
angetreten sind weil wir natürlich die
Verpflichtung haben auch internationale
Klimaziele einzuhalten welche Koalition
der Film Frage kommt wie gesagt da kann
ich nur noch mal darauf verweisen dass
wir hier jetzt sicher nicht den
richtigen Punkt haben um darüber zu
reden auch mit wem man sich da annähern
kann aber vielleicht auch noch mal den
Link hin zur FDP ich finde es ja auch
ganz spannend noch mal aus dieser
wirtschaftlichen Perspektive ich bin ja
auch Wirtschaftsingenieurin vom
Hintergrund und finde es immer sehr
bedauerlich dass gerade von Seiten der
FDP die sagt ganze Themenkomplex
Klimaschutz sehr stark auch auf
Finanzinstrumente runtergespielt wird
also dass man eben mit einem
Emissionshandel auch alle Klimaziel
erreichen kann daran glaube ich nicht
weil immer wieder dieser Faktor Zeit
auch zu kurz kommt es ist eben doch so
dass wenn wir einfach sagen wir machen
jetzt CO2 erheblich teurer dann wird der
Markt vielleicht Regeln aber wie können
wir dann vielleicht vom Auto auf den Bus
umsteigen wenn der Bus noch gar nicht
fährt also wir werden ganz sicher
ordnungsrechtliche Instrumente auch
brauchen wir werden einen Ausbau der
Infrastruktur brauchen Klimaschutz
funktioniert nur mit Investitionen die
aber auch natürlich die Lebensqualität
dann steigern aber alleine nur mit
Finanzinstrumenten glaube ich ist das
nicht realistisch umzusetzen also wir
merken schon dass es ein
leidenschaftliches Plädoyer wie man es
von einer grünen Politikerin auch
erwartet aber die FDP ist hat das Thema
mit Sicherheit auch erkannt in den
letzten Jahren am Klimaschutz kommt
keiner vorbei wie sehen Sie das Herr
motorst also sie haben jetzt gerade
schon gehört von ihrer Kollegin bei den
Grünen wird schon auch auf
Ordnungspolitik gesetzt die FDP setzt
der traditionell mehr auf Innovationen
wie es ihre Haltung
völlig richtig und ich bin da ähnlich
leidenschaftlich wie Frau Meier das
möchte ich gar nicht abgesprochen
bekommen wir haben gesagt wir fordern
harten CO2 Deckel und da wurde gab es
auch verschiedene Erhebungen darüber
dass das sehr effektiv wäre und wenn das
zu sozialen Ungleichheiten führt was ja
auch gerade angesprochen wurde woraufhin
gedeutet wurde dann wollen wir ähnlich
wie die Grünen wir nennen das
klima-dividende die nun grünen nennen
das energiegeld dafür sorgen dass gerade
bei den kleinen Einkommen die vielleicht
übermäßig belastet sind weil sie pendeln
müssen das ganze ausgeglichen wird also
es ist kein sozial kaltes Programm wir
wollen genauso dass Deutschland seine
Klimaziele erreicht machen dazu eher
einen großen Vorschlag und dann eben die
Innovation zu aktivieren das
allerwichtigste Thema ist aber bei
Klimaschutz und das wird gerne vergessen
ich glaube aber dass wir damit den
Grünen zusammenkommen die Investitionen
international denn gerade im globalen
Süden können die Menschen nicht mal eben
auf Wohlstand verzichten wir müssen dort
investieren also Klimaschutz mit
wirtschaftlichen Wachstum mit rauskommen
aus der Armut verbinden nur dann machen
wir es möglich dass wir nicht nur für
uns in unserem kleinen Kosmos so ein
bisschen Co reduzieren das ist wichtig
dass wir unsere Ziele erreichen es ist
aber mindestens so wichtig dass
Deutschland als technologienation dazu
beiträgt dass auch international
wirklich CO2 reduziert wird in Zukunft
ja oder vielleicht gerade auch noch mal
die Nachfrage bei Frau Meier wie sehen
sie den internationalen Zusammenhang
klar also wir werden als Deutschland
nicht den Klimawandel aufhalten können
die Klimakrise können wir nicht alleine
lösen aber natürlich ist es auch keine
Ausrede jetzt konsequenten Klimaschutz
zu machen sondern wir müssen als
Vorreiter Vorgehen wir haben natürlich
auch die Möglichkeiten wenn wir hier
Systeme Technologien etablieren das auch
die Welt davon profitieren kann und
natürlich macht man sich es auch immer
leichter in globalen Verhandlungen wenn
man dann auch eben mit einem sehr guten
Modell schon am Start ist das auch
funktioniert Deutschland hat die
bestmöglichen Bedingungen dafür wir sind
wirtschaftlich stark aufgestellt wir
haben eine starke Bevölkerung eine
starke Zivilgesellschaft die Klimaschutz
möchte das haben wir gerade auch bei
dieser Wahl gesehen und das sind glaube
ich die allerbesten Voraussetzungen um
auch in internationale Verhandlungen
einzusteigen Lacker Hashtag one schreibt
uns über Youtube ich will kein
Tempolimit auch das wäre ja eine
Maßnahme die die Grünen befürworten im
Zusammenhang mit dem Klimaschutz
absolutes No-Go schreibt er
Investitionen Digitalisierung
Entbürokratisierung und Klimaschutz
haben aber bei dem Ansatz gemeinsam da
gibt es sicher einen Mittelweg wie
wichtig ist das Tempolimit für die
Grünen Frau Meier
ja das Thema Tempolimit ist natürlich
auch ein sehr leidenschaftliches Thema
da glaube ich muss man gar nicht
abstreiten dass es auch polarisiert für
uns steht die Gesundheit der Menschen
auch an einem ganz oberen Punkt also das
Thema Vision Zero und wir wollen keine
Toten mehr im Verkehr haben
perspektivisch das wird auch nur
funktionieren indem wir auch ein
Tempolimit einführen das also der Aspekt
Klima ist dann natürlich auch noch mal
was was mit dazu kommt und die
Reduzierung von Emissionen durch ein
Tempolimit ich glaube aber auch
Tempolimit wird einfach eine Sache sein
wo wir dann auch schauen wie wir
gemeinsam auf einen Nenner kommen
ich habe noch im Ohr freie Fahrt für
freie Bürger ist schon ein bisschen
älter das Motto aber ich nehme an da hat
sich an der Grundposition ihrer Partei
wenig geändert oder wie ist das
ist schon ein bisschen herfällig richtig
ich bin froh dass Frau Meier direkt sagt
und darum geht es ja auch das ist nicht
so sehr ein klima-thema sondern
Sicherheitsthema da kann man das immer
diskutieren meine Position ist da
relativ klar die deutschen Autobahnen
sind mit die sichersten Straßen der Welt
wir haben eher das Problem auf den
Landstraßen und dann lieber mit
intelligenter Verkehrssteuer die
Verkehrssteuerung ein
Unfallschwerpunkten dafür sorgen dass
man das Risiko in Zukunft reduziert fürs
Klima natürlich würde es sofort etwas
reduzieren aber mal ein Beispiel ich bin
gestern 30 Minuten auf Parkplatzsuche
gewesen bei mir zu Hause wenn man es mal
schaffen würde dass man in der Stadt
nicht mehr ewig auf Parkplatzsuche ist
und sinnlos CO2 umher schleudert würde
man deutlich schneller deutlich mehr CO2
reduzieren also es eher an
Sicherheitsthema das Tempolimit kein
Klimathema und da haben wir
unterschiedliche Positionen das braucht
man gar nicht leugnen gut dann haben wir
hier mal einen Dissens den wir an dieser
Stelle festhalten der aber sich
eventuell ja auch dann in den
entsprechenden Verhandlungen noch
auflösen lassen würde wir kommen zum
nächsten Thema zum dritten und da ist
sogar das Grundgesetz involviert es geht
um die Schuldenbremse auch hier noch mal
die Position der Parteien und die
Expertenmeinung
die Schuldenbremse ist im Grundgesetz
verankert um das zu ändern wird eine 2/3
Mehrheit benötigt die hätten weder Ampel
noch Jamaika-Koalition die FDP will die
Schuldenbremse nicht aufweichen fordert
aber Möglichkeiten für Investitionen
nötige Ausgaben wie zum Beispiel für den
Klimaschutz oder die Digitalisierung
sollten maßgeblich von der
Privatwirtschaft getragen werden die
Grünen wollen die Schuldenbremse um eine
investitionsregel ergänzen also eine
Form der Schuldenbremse die ermöglicht
dass mehr investiert wird an Stellen wo
neues Vermögen geschaffen wird das sind
zum Beispiel Investitionen in
Klimaschutz aber auch in Bildung oder
neue Sozialbauten lassen sich diese
Gegensätze überbrücken und wenn ja am
besten mit Union oder SPD
eine formelle Änderung der
Schuldenbremse kann ohnehin nur mit
Zustimmung aller vier Parteien erfolgen
deshalb ist es viel wahrscheinlicher
dass man Versuch gehört Wege um die
Schuldenbremse herumzufinden und das
sind dann typischerweise
ausgelagerte
investitionsgesellschaften mit denen man
dann zum Beispiel größere
Infrastrukturprojekte finanziert egal ob
mit SPD oder CDU
egal ob mit SPD oder CDU sagte Experte
also die Schuldenbremse das ist klar ist
im Grundgesetz verankert die FDP will
sie auf jeden Fall beibehalten Herr Mord
aus einerseits braucht es ja auch
Investitionen unter anderem um eben bei
der Digitalisierung und auch bei
Infrastrukturmaßnahmen aber auch zum
Beispiel was den Klimawandel angeht
dafür für Investitionen eben zu sorgen
sehen sie da Verhandlungsspielraum
bei der bei dem Erhalt der
Schuldenbremse gibt es für uns ist es
eine rote Linie gibt es kein
Verhandlungsspielraum das haben wir auch
von Anfang an gesagt ist auch ziemlich
unrealistisch mit einer
Zweidrittelmehrheit das zu ändern
insofern glaube ich ist das eine
Scheindiskussion die einige führen was
für mich entscheidend ist die meist das
meiste der Investition kommt aus dem
privaten Sektor 90% bereits jetzt also
wie viel Schulden will man machen um da
irgendwie ein Gleichgewicht rein zu
bekommen insofern glaube ich private
Investitionen Aktivieren der Staat muss
seine Kernaufgaben erfüllen Schule
Schiene Sicherheit darum müssen wir uns
kümmern dass es mit den jetzigen
finanziellen Mitteln bereits möglich
insofern glaube ich ist es sinnvoll und
gut an diesem an diesem Teil unserer
Verfassung festzuhalten Frau Meier
machen sie sich Hoffnungen auf eine
Zweidrittelmehrheit irgendwann um das zu
ändern
ja so Tatsache ist wir haben mit
Deutschland rückläufige Investitionen in
den letzten Jahren wir machen zwar auf
den Papier so gesehen keine neuen
Schulden also im Normalbetrieb nehmen
jetzt mal Corona raus aber Tatsache ist
einfach dass unsere öffentliche
Infrastruktur auch immer mehr verkommt
gerade das Thema Sanierung von Gebäuden
mit voran unsere Schulen oder das Thema
ja Instandhaltung von Bahnschienen und
Co das sind zwar Sachen die wie gesagt
in den Büchern nicht auftauchen aber wo
wir mit mir ein ganz ernsthaftes Problem
haben jede kluge Unternehmerin weiß in
Niedrigzinsphasen macht es durchaus Sinn
auch meinen Kredit aufzunehmen wenn man
weniger Geld zurückzahlen muss als man
an Krediten aufnimmt dann sind
Investitionen sehr wichtig das ist ja
eigentlich auch ein Grundsatz der FDP
deswegen finde ich spannend dass das so
kategorisch ausgeschlossen wird für uns
wäre das eine Multiplikation der
Schuldenbremse wir wollen die
Schuldenbremse an sich natürlich auch
behalten aber wir wollen gerade im
Hinblick auf Investitionen also nicht
Konsumausgaben die Schuldenbremse
modifizieren Herr mortos wollen sie da
noch mal erwidern
ja selbstverständlich also es ist völlig
richtig dass wir investieren müssen das
habe ich auch nicht bezweifelt aber in
vielen Stellen ist das Geld schon
vorhanden Beispiel Schule digitalpakt
wird nicht auf wird nicht abgerufen
Beispiel Ausbauziele von Windenergie da
sind gibt es bereits die Ziele die
werden aber jetzt schon nicht erfüllt
also es bringt nichts immer nur die
Ziele zu erhöhen oder neue Mittel
bereitzustellen die Mitteln müssen auch
abgerufen werden und das ist ein
bürokratieproblem in Deutschland und da
müssen wir wann und das reduzieren bzw
schneller machen digitaler machen dann
werden die Mittel die da sind auch
abgerufen immer neue Mittel einspeisen
bringt nichts wenn die die schon da sind
nicht abgerufen werden also das mit
Sicherheit ein Problem die
co2-bepreisung ist ein anderes an die
Mulle über Facebook schreibt hallo Herr
Mordhorst was heißt das für Unternehmen
und Haushalte wie viel kostet die Tonne
CO2 mit der FDP wird der Preis nicht in
kürzester Zeit explodieren
das kann ich nicht sagen und ich glaube
das ist vom Politikern auch relativ
unseriös Preise festzulegen was klar ist
wir brauchen einen Deckel also klar
sagen wie viel CO2 können wir noch
ausstoßen und die Einnahmen die wieder
dadurch generieren also es wurde ja
gerade in den Beitrag auch gesagt man
soll nicht zu sehr an den Staatshaushalt
dran darum geht es auch die Einnahmen
die daraus generiert werden sollen eins
zu eins an die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
zurückgegeben werden einmal durch eine
klare auf also durch eine klare pro
kopfverteilung das gerade die
profitieren dieser wenig haben aber auch
zum Beispiel an die Stromsteuer an die
EEG-Umlage wollen wir ran davon sind
auch gerade kleine Unternehmen belastet
wir haben hohe Strompreise in
Deutschland und ich glaube an diesen
Stellen können wir sozialen Ausgleich
schaffen damit kein Unternehmen dadurch
pleite geht und damit auch Bürgerinnen
und Bürger keine finanzielle Angst vor
Klimaschutz haben müssen
interessanterweise kommt jetzt gerade
noch mal eine Frage an Herrn mortus den
nehme ich gerade noch mit rein und zwar
von Rico Müller wäre die FDP bereit
klimaschädliche Subventionen abzubauen
um klimafreundliche Technologien nicht
mehr zu benachteiligen und auch die von
den Grünen geforderten Steuererhöhungen
entscheiden zu können
die muss man sich im Einzelnen anschauen
da gibt es schöne Berechnungen dass man
bis zu 70 Milliarden Subventionen im
Jahr einsparen könnte das muss man sich
dann im Einzelnen anschauen
grundsätzlich klimaschädliche
Subventionen abzubauen ist aber keine
schlechte Idee deswegen grundsätzlich ja
dann noch mal eine Frage an Frau Meier
von Yolo Hater 88 welche Kompromisse
wären die Grünen in den Verhandlungen
mit der FDP bereit zu machen welche ihre
Forderung hat Priorität bleiben wir mal
was diese Frage angeht beim Thema Klima
ja okay also gerade beim Klima habe ich
ja schon angesprochen da wird mit uns
sicherlich nicht so wahnsinnig viel
Kompromiss drin sein das ist unser
Kernthema mit dem wir für diese Wahlen
angetreten sind und die Pariser
Klimaziele die stehen für uns auch
wirklich an oberster Stelle jetzt für
diese Verhandlung klar ist natürlich
auch wir können darüber streiten mit
welchen Instrumenten kommt man denn am
besten zu diesen Zielen aber bei den
Zielen da müssen wir uns einfach auch an
die internationalen Verträge sprich das
Pariser Klimaziel halten
verstehe gut dann vielleicht noch eine
Frage auch von mir wie geht es denn
jetzt eigentlich weiter das wäre
vielleicht auch noch mal ganz
interessant so rein pragmatischen morgen
soll ja noch mal jeweils parteiintern
evaluiert werden können Sie da
vielleicht noch mal was zu sagen wie ist
jetzt so das weitere Prozedere in den
Parteien
dann fragen wir doch bei den FDP
Kollegen zuerst Herr Motors
ich finde das Wort parteiinternen
evaluieren fast es schon gut zusammen
das war kurz und bündig Frau Meier
wollen sie es vielleicht etwas weiter
ausführen
ja diesmal hatten wir der max-morahs
auch einfach abgenommen was ich sonst
gesagt hätte genau ich sehe schon ich
kriege da nicht viel aus ihnen raus soll
ich jetzt noch fragen welche koalitions
am Ende wird
ganz beruhigend auch dass wir beim Thema
ich finde es total beruhigend dass wir
beim Thema Vertraulichkeit auch da
einfach auf einer Linie sind das ist ja
auch wirklich was was unsere Demokratie
stärkt wenn geheime Verhandlungen eben
auch erstmal geheim bleiben man muss ja
auch dann eine vertrauensvolle und
respektvolle Basis schaffen und es wird
sicher nicht funktionieren indem ja
jeder Abgeordnete also jeder Abgeordnete
jeder Abgeordnete rausläuft und einfach
mal dann auch in die Welt schreit was
man sich dann am liebsten wünschen würde
und was nicht oder auch vielleicht schon
interner rausplaudert genau also muss
ich auch ihren beiden oder ihren
Parteien dann auch zugestehen dass auch
als Medien schaffender das ist in der
Tat beachtlich der herrscht wirklich
offenbar eine große Diskretion
jedenfalls was ihre beiden Parteien
angeht und das ist der Sache natürlich
förderlich für uns ist es manchmal ein
bisschen schade habe ich ihn wieder
nichts entblocken können aber okay damit
muss ich mich jetzt abfinden aber danke
dass ich zugeben ja das mache ich gerne
ich danke Ihnen beiden für das Gespräch
es hat mir viel Spaß gemacht danke auch
noch mal an unsere User es gebe
natürlich noch das eine oder andere
Thema nachdem ich hier auch gefragt
worden bin zu besprechen aber das würde
jetzt den Rahmen dieses Livestreams
sprengen ich hatte ihnen gesagt es wird
eine gute halbe Stunde etwa gehen und in
dieser Zeit sind wir in etwa geblieben
also noch mal vielen Dank an sie beide
eine gute erste Zeit im Bundestag
erfolgreiche erste vier Jahre wünsche
ich Ihnen danke schön und auch noch mal
unsere User besten Dank und einen
schönen Abend bis demnächst